rachel i cannot wait to take you on a
ghost adventure with my man
zach bagens oh no not gonna happen that
is all you can
i got you listen i have literally been
scared to my core with that dude on
multiple occasions
but what zack has cooked up for his
latest investigation
is the most bone-chilling terrifying
excursion
that he has ever been on i mean it
as a paranormal investigator it doesn't
get any
bigger and more sinister than this and
there's a reason why this hotel
has inspired other horror productions
like american horror story hotel
you seem nervous when you walk into that
building it's like you cannot even
control
your own mind well maybe this place is
special the cecil hotel in los angeles
has been the site of
16 mysterious deaths and downs acts
looking into the most recent true crime
the disappearance of elisa lamb you may
remember seeing this viral video
where she was seen acting erratically in
the hotel's elevator you could see a
lisa lamb
in this corner so elisa lamb was found
in this water tank
and they couldn't explain how she got it
and how the lid was put back on the
water tank 100
there's no way she could have gotten in
there and then closed the lid but not
only that but her clothes were found
floating at the bottom of the tank the
two-hour special
ghost adventures cecil hotel is
streaming down on discovery plus
but the hotel isn't the only disturbing
thing zach's been up to
you bought the chucky doll i did hi
it's me chucky here you asked that
hi kevin how are you doing there that
that doesn't scare the crap out of you
and you also bought the famous um clown
doll from poltergeist
i did yeah i don't have it in my house i
have it in the next room
i actually had to take it out of my
house because honestly it scared the
crap out of it
zach has a portion of his museum that is
just
clowns wall-to-wall and you have to walk
through it's a lot y'all that's all i
can say
it's a lot